so  i brought gifts to the ladies  oh i gave them um some girly things like  cosmetics  bracelets a nail shaper  and then i gave her brother some  some spiky uh gel for his hair  because i know guys like something like  that and because  because moms are special one  is  okay  [Music]  so we have two bedrooms in here one for  my brother and  one for my sister and my mom and my dad  this is our tiny kitchen wow that is a  lot of rice  yep your house reminds me of pedro's  grandma's house  is it better it's better than the camp  we tried to say no  yeah because like you said you say like  it's look better than the campbell  it really reminded me of your grandma's  house this is the campus like  more clean more organized more good  it's like he's like very crowded  it's like a lot of people it's like it's  very 100 different  [Music]  you